please be sort of the darkness  people have been trying to make  foundation for over 50 years foundation  was an enormous influence for Star Wars  it was the greatest science fiction work  of all time the story is sprawling the  scope is sprawling it unfolds over the  course of a thousand years if ever there  were a company that was hoping to sort  of better people's lives through  technology through connectivity it's  Apple and that's something very much  that Asimov was hoping to do  they aim to arrest me tomorrow and you  so much to certainty  you're familiar with my work  psychohistory yes in theory but I don't  know what it has to do is not a theory  [Music]  they're worried you can predict the  future  why people believe I can  and they don't like the future I  predicted  [Music]  the Empire will fall order will vanish  this massive events rushing to Eva's  believe even short of the darkness  [Music]  you  you